kawhi take it in the escape hatch was
there but he couldn't find
the finish on the other way georgetown
foul beverly things are starting to get
a little chippy here kevin
beverly comes in and things changing and
crowder didn't like it
and they may take a look at this as well
we may take a look at this look at the
blow here by
beverly yeah
that's a chicken wing yep that's an
elbow right there
for the appropriate penalty yep this is
going to be a flagrant one
i'm patrick beverly that's an easy call
you were told reggie jackson by the way
has been taken to the locker room
they're taking a look at his eye
[Applause]
clippers
between these two teams they got into it
earlier as well
well you're referring to booker and paul
george
that was a five-point win for the
clippers over the suns
i like it i like it
this is two scrappy guards going at each
other here
reggie it cannot it cannot be overstated
how important chris paul has been
in his first year with phoenix and him
and the trust monty williams has in him
on the floor well that was a hip and an
elbow and
all kinds of stuff and close to other
regions as well too i would be surprised
if this is not a flagrant one yeah
more arm than hip but there uh there he
went flying
[Applause]
if the season ended right now reggie
these two teams would meet in the second
round
how fun would that be yeah it's the real
players has been used to determine this
file to be unnecessary and excessive
and patrick beverly will be ejected from
the game wow
oh wow now i wasn't expecting that
[Applause]
well he was on a minute's restrictions
anyway so it doesn't really hurt
it doesn't really hurt the clippers
because you still have rondo and reggie
jackson and reggie jackson
has gone to the back already because of
the eye injury right
yes so now you just have rondo yeah
beverly has played
17 minutes he's capped at 20.
rondo has played 14. not quite sure what
his number is but they are
under a limit with the minutes they can
play
so beverly ejected hey kev
you know what another thing another
thing that's kind of in play here too
is his reputation right patrick beverly
kind of has a reputation of
kind of getting in your face and doing
things that
kind of crossed the line a little bit
i'm sure that played a part
meanwhile